Salut romain ça va ?
bof j'ai la diarrhée.
Ha !  c'est dans la tête ça !
Ha ! non non ça c'est plutôt...
Oui bon et sinon ?
J'ai de l'eczéma !
Ha ! Ba c'est dans la tête aussi.
Ha ! non là c'est sur mon...
Oui, oui ok... et donc ?
Je suis un peu stressé.
Bah voilà ! C'est ce que je disais.
On a longtemps imaginé le corps et l'esprit comme deux choses complètement distinctes
Pourtant les sportifs savent ça mieux que tout le monde: le mental et le physique ça marche ensemble
Où ça marche pas.
Au coeur de cette histoire il y a un organe mystérieux quasi mystique...
Le cerveau !
C'est cet endroit où se mélangent nos émotions, nos pensées, nos humeurs mais aussi celui qui commande notre système nerveux donc...
notre corps.
Du coup quand on sait ça on se doute bien qu'il y a des chances pour que les deux aspects soient liés.
Et vous savez quoi ?
Bah on a raison.
Et oui en réalité imaginer une distinction totale entre le corps et l'esprit
ça n'a aucun sens. Parce qu'on est des créatures complexes, on a plusieurs dimensions: la dimension biologique
c'est à dire notre corps. La dimension psychologique, c'est à dire notre esprit. Et celle de notre environnement ,nos relations aux autres etc
c'est à dire la dimension sociale et les trois sont intimement liés, donc notre santé elle dépend pas uniquement de facteurs biologiques.
Les éléments de notre vie sociale ils ont des conséquences sur notre psychisme, qui lui-même influe sur notre corps
et réciproquement et vice et versa et tutti quanti.
J'avoue c'est un peu abstrait. Bon imaginons un événement nul dans votre vie sociale
une rupture, vous perdez votre job, un de vos proches meurt
je ne vous ne souhaite pas, c'est juste pour l'exemple ce genre d'événement ça a forcément des répercussions sur votre moral.
Donc sur votre psychisme. Alors imaginons maintenant que suite à ça vous fassiez une dépression. Attention la dépression c'est pas juste être en mode
[Hello darkness my old friend]
C'est une vraie maladie, la dépression en plus des manifestations
psychologique et sociales,  elle a aussi des conséquences physiques
et par plusieurs mécanismes différents. D'abord la dépression elle provoque des troubles de plusieurs grandes fonctions
comme le sommeil ou l'appétit par exemple. Et ça ça a déjà des répercussions sur votre corps, la fatigue, l'amaigrissement, les carences alimentaires
du coup on est plus sensible aux maladies. Et effectivement
les personnes dépressives sont plus malades que les autres, et la dépression elle
provoque aussi des douleurs physiques
dans les membres dans les articulations,
au niveau de la tête, au niveau du ventre etc
Plusieurs études ont été menées sur le sujet, et en observant le cerveau des personnes dépressives grâce à une IRM
les différentes équipes ont constaté plusieurs choses : d'abord que les différents réseaux responsables de la douleur étaient
effectivement activés et donc la douleur elle était bien réelle et que ce n'est pas une vue de l'esprit
ensuite que chez les patients souffrant de dépression, ces réseaux réagissent plus fortement que chez les autres, donc notre état psychologique peut déclencher
des douleurs et les amplifier, mais il peut aussi provoquer ou au moins
déclencher certaines maladies. On appelle ça les maladies psychosomatiques.
Mais attention, contrairement à ce que beaucoup de gens pensent
psychosomatiques ça veut pas dire "c'est dans ta tête  c'est pas vrai". ça veut juste dire que c'est un problème organique donc physique
causé par le psychisme
et ça mérite d'être soigné comme n'importe quelle maladie. En plus des douleurs chroniques dont on a déjà parlé, les facteurs psychologiques
comme les émotions fortes ou le stress ça peut déclencher des crises d'asthme;
des maladies de peau comme le psoriasis ou l'eczéma,
des ulcères à l'estomac etc. Et si on prend le cas des pathologies cardiovasculaires
évidemment le stress est pas le seul en cause, mais il fait partie des facteurs qui augmentent votre risque de développer une maladie
mais aussi de déclencher une crise. Genre la fameuse crise cardiaque,
si vous voulez faire votre malin en soirée, on dit l'infarctus du myocarde
cadeau, essayons d'être encore plus concrète on peut même transformer son corps de façon visible et immédiate par la seule force de son esprit.
Vous savez quoi faire une expérience,
Fermez les yeux
désormais visualisez une forme,  une forme humaine
C'est un corps, un corps désirable qui s'approche du vôtre jusqu'à le frôler et l'effleurer.
Du sang afflue actuellement dans vos corps caverneux, votre corps est en train de se transformer.
En vrai c'est pas juste une blague, vos images mentales elles provoquent
des émotions
qui provoquent elles mêmes des réactions physiques. Qui ont elles mêmes des répercussions sur vos organes. Bon mais comment ça marche en vrai ?
pas le coup du sang qui arrive dans votre euh... Comment ce à quoi vous pensez peut avoir une influence sur votre corps ?
hé bien d'une certaine manière on en a déjà parlé dans la vidéo" pourquoi le stress donne la diarrhée ?"
On est pile dans le thème? Pour comprendre ce qui se passe, en gros faut savoir un ou deux trucs sur notre système nerveux,
déjà pour résumer on en a pas un on en a deux. Celui qui nous sert à avoir des sensations
genre le chaud le froid la douleur etc mais aussi à faire des mouvements, genre marcher ou faire les gestes qu'on veut.
Il ya celui qui est sur pilote automatique, qu'on appelle le système nerveux
autonome,  et qui gère nos grandes fonctions vitales genre la respiration, les battements de notre cœur et notre digestion
et c'est celui-là qui nous intéresse.En gros il a le pouvoir
d'accélérer ou de ralentir
l'activité de nos organes vitaux, Mais aussi de changer la taille de nos bronches ou de nos vaisseaux sanguins. Et tout ça, ça a des
conséquences comme faire monter ou baisser notre tension
déclencher la sécrétion de certaines substances, ou nous donner la diarrhée
Voilà bon mais pourquoi il fait ça notre système nerveux autonome ?
Pourquoi il fait le mariole comme ça ?
bah globalement il réagit à des signaux d'alerte qui indiquent qu'il y a quelque chose qui va pas et qui sont transmis par
notre cerveau et parmi ces signaux , pour garder le même exemple un bon coup de stress
ça peut être perçu par notre cerveau comme une menace immédiate pour notre survie.
Du coup le cerveau bah il transmet l'info et le corps se met en mode commando pour être prêt
soit à fuir
soit à combattre et tout ça si c'est répété ça peut avoir des conséquences durables sur nos organes et donc sur notre santé . Bon alors
j'avoue pour le moment c'est pas ouf , on a un peu l'impression que notre esprit c'est l'ennemi de notre corps mais en fait non
d'abord parce que, oui être mal dans sa tête ça a des conséquences
négatives sur le corps mais du coup à l'inverse , être bien dans sa tête ça a des conséquences
positives, Ne serait-ce que ne pas avoir de conséquences négatives. Puis il y a les endorphines par exemple
les hormones du plaisir, du bonheur, du bien-être, vous trouverez plein de mots pour les décrire.
Elles sont libérées dans différentes circonstances mais notamment quand vous vous faites plaisir, quand vous faites du bien, de différentes façons
Elles ont en effet à la fois apaisant et euphorisant et elles calment même les douleurs , c'est quand même pas mal .
tient la douleur d'ailleurs voilà un truc physique qu'on peut contrôler avec son esprit
*cris de douleur*
Tout simplement parce que c'est pas une sensation purement physique c'est un processus complexe qui est contrôlé par
différentes zones du cerveau et qu'on peut désactiver certaines de ces zones
par différents moyens en faisant diversion par exemple c'est à dire en se concentrant sur une activité mentale,
Genre compter. Et si on veut aller encore plus loin . On veut ?
Oui aller on veut, si on veut aller encore plus loin on peut parler de ces couples âgés qui meurent à quelques jours voire à quelques heures
d'intervalle ou des malades en fin de vie qui attendent la visite d'un proche qui vient de très loin
et qui décèdent quelques heures après les avoir vus. Là on est dans l'exemple ultime
du pouvoir de l'esprit sur le corps, celui de se maintenir en vie ou passer de l'autre côté
dans tous les cas et pour toutes les raisons qu'on vient de voir on peut se mettre d'accord sur un truc c'est pas parce que
c'est dans la tête qu'il faut rien faire. Quand un trouble semble psychosomatique
d'abord il faut soigner les signes physiques pour qu'ils soient moins douloureux et moins gênants. Mais il faut aussi soigner la cause
donc la souffrance psychologique. Genre chez un psy.
Reminder aller chez un psy ça veut pas dire qu'on est dingue,
et quand bien même quand on a mal aux dents on va chez le dentiste avant que ça pourrisse
et ben c'est pareil avec les troubles psychologiques, et les psys. Et puis même sans parler de maladie, globalement
vivre heureux c'est toujours mieux
Voilà dtc c'est fini pour aujourd'hui. On se retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle vidéo. D'ici là plus que jamais, et maintenant vous savez pourquoi,
mettez vous bien et du coup
portez vous bien